hey guys so right now we're backstage at
the game awards i'm so excited because i
get to present an award with buggy
so i feel really bad because i'm like a
newcomer to your channel but i like last
night honestly that's all i did was
watch and i was like my first reaction
was like this dude is awesome and he
seems like the nicest person ever and
it's confirmed like you really are i try
unless it's on the other hand let me
tell you something he's a real douche
man i don't know i like that guy i like
me i don't like freshness it happens
but i'm so excited to meet you this is
so fun yeah this has been awesome it's
been so great we've been hanging out all
day we've been talking about the stuff
we're talking about youtube talking
about you guys and we love you and we
really do love you guys she loves you
more than i do i mean you know it's it's
a give and take but it's it's an equal
love
well i'll tell you one thing we both
really love video games so this is so
exciting we're announcing the trending
gamer and i think you announced the
official winner right so i know who it
is just told me who it is
and this guy deserves like i'm not gonna
say i'm not gonna spoil anything wow
wow by the time this is posted
they'll already know but it's okay cuz
you guys can watch it again live okay uh
we gotta go out soon now let's go
29.88
what is up
so we are here to present the award for
trending gamer because well we're always
scouring the internet for new trends
isn't that right well it's pretty much
our job to keep track of what's trending
on the internet right it is so no what's
trending right now checking twitter
better be the game awards
looks like it's cats
to present game of the year it's been an
amazing night i want to thank you all
for coming out uh for those industry the
fans have been here so much energy all
night
winner here for the game awards and that
winner is
stay tuned
very tightly taped here
the winner is
dragon age inquisition
imagine dragons
hey guys so i am uh i'm back from the
game awards the show was awesome jeff
keeley did such a great job of putting
everything together and just
tying the whole community together i'm
kind of excited even though i'm such a
huge call of duty fan and i was cheering
for call of duty to win the best shooter
far cry 4 won but of course far cry 3
should have won game of the year last
year but either way i love far cry so
much so i was pretty excited about that
and definitely one of my highlights was
presenting an award with boogie we
presented the trending gamer award and
total biscuit one so congratulations
whoa crowd is wild maybe i'll put a
cheering clapping in here and no i can't
i'm too tired to do that anyway it was
so awesome getting to present with him
and meet him and it's so crazy because
there's so many youtubers now and i was
like how have i not come across your
youtube videos in
my youtubing
video watching binging i don't know and
now i have to go to bed because i'm
heading to esl tomorrow and i'm going to
be hanging out with intel so i'm kind of
excited about that i love getting to
work with them everyone at intel is so
nice i love working and meeting people
that are nice like it is just it's so
important just be nice just be nice to
people like that's like it's not really
that hard of a concept like just don't
be a dick all right time for bed i'm
starving and all that we have here is
candy
what are you oh my god okay
oh shoot i gotta put this back or i'm
gonna pay for it
more water and the technology kit like
this is this is not filling i'm just
gonna go to bed and go for breakfast so
um yeah i don't know what i'm saying i'm
too tired i'll see you tomorrow happy
vlogmas day
something
hope you guys are enjoying vlogmas um
yeah it's really weird vlogging every
day but i hope you guys enjoy it i love
you
i don't think i've made any sense but
that's okay